hearing all these percentages I'm not
even gonna lie
[Music]
okay what about you top 20 of women
uh
I'll just say they'll just have to be
Housewives literally are you top 20 of
women yeah I might yeah I would be
qualified to be a house okay
take all the boxes
top 20 of women yes or no yeah
absolutely yeah
um and you said no
um no no
big up you look man
well I think I've been a housewife I
might be a bit bored yeah I could I've
got like a question you're saying do we
our values qualify or do we want to can
you say which one that's what are you
asking us no I was asking if you think
you're in the top 20 of women
in the eyes of men in the eyes of men
but to be fair with the numbers you'd
always screaming out you sort of are in
it yeah
you win 20 you know
in an Ideal World I'd want to pay 20 but
we don't live in an ideal world we live
in the real world and I'm not ignorant
to the fact that I'm not in the top 20
of women so I don't expect to be a
stay-at-home housewife and have things
how I want
um I don't know where people get the
idea that life's supposed to be exactly
how you want it life is how it is and
you deal with it how you're supposed to
given your circumstances my
circumstances are I'm not top 20 so I'm
probably going to be working what age do
you guys think traditional women get
married by
[Music]
maybe 21 between 21 and yeah before
you're 20 100 so like maybe 19 to 24 25
I would say 20.
yeah
I would say between age of 21 and 25 21
and 25 25 okay yeah I would have said
25. who do you guys think benefits more
from the institution of marriage in 2023
men or women women
[Music]
yo
no but I don't think it's just money
like I feel like it's like but it's the
institution of marriage not the not the
values of marriage the institution and
women benefit from the institution
massively well I think normally the men
that have like earn a lot of money and
they're like the main Breadwinners
sometimes like
um it ended with a lot of domestic like
violence and stuff because they feel
like they're I think that's a bold
assumption okay cool yeah that is a
broad assumption let me just shut up
but still no but I feel like sometimes
like men that make a lot of money they
have a lot more entitlement though I
think it's definitely so does
entitlement equate domestic violence no
not domestic violence but like I mean
what do you mean by entitlement
because they think okay I'm the man
you're the woman I'm earning money and
you're not so whatever I say like goes
it's not a thing where it's like rolls
where it's like okay cool I can respect
that you're cooking and cleaning it's
more of a thing where I'm making the
money and that's that you know we are
harder but we all just said that we
would have a hard time respecting
someone if we made more money than them
when it comes to decision making so
don't you think if he's paying all the
bills he should have the final say in
decision making yes otherwise go find a
guy to split it 50 50 worth yeah no I
feel like he should have the final like
but at the same time as you said before
I feel like there still needs to be a
conversation Andrew if you're my in the
right man you'll submit to him and yeah
there should still be and he'll get the
final say but I feel like a lot of men
that are earning they'll just last thing
I have a question
do you want to have a conversation with
your girl about every decision you guys
make nope
but guys don't want to do
it and it's kind of like if the dude's
providing a lifestyle where you get to
be in the top 20.
important decision he can consult you
and I think if you're with a guy for
long enough he's going to consult you
maybe but he also might not that's like
the bosses you know like a boss might go
to their best employee and ask their
opinion but at the end of the day who's
whose decision is it
um
and then the employee doesn't go to the
boss and say you need to have a
conversation with me
okay but you keep doing the employee and
boss I think it's very like different a
relationship yeah I mean I agree I mean
it's different but it's the same
principle it's the concept yeah
I get what you mean I I understand what
you mean like if if that's the lifestyle
that we want we have to kind of be
willing to accept what it comes with but
who says that it has to come with
control and like having to obey someone
I don't like that idea like yes he's
providing this life for me but he's also
providing this life for his kids as well
you know and I'm sure he's the man yeah
the man that make the money say that no
I'm I'm saying that he is obviously
providing for his family so some men are
actually happy doing that they actually
want their wife to stay at home and
spend time with their kids and not it's
not it's not a bad thing yeah I'm not
hating on anyone for wanting wanting
what they want but but what does he get
in return and those guys typically want
submission in return and submission is
and we have to have a conversation every
time I want to
I think women are kind of confused in a
sense like you've got the modern woman
who wants to say traditionally like how
she is with in her views but like it's
contradiction it's contradiction
contradicting it
um both values because she wants to be a
stay-at-home mom but she still wants to
have a say in the household and fight
for the equality with the confusion of
the feminism thing okay it's like a
challenge sorry let me just jump in
there quickly so for example if
something happens with your kids
um there was an issue in the house
um and for example you and your husband
did not agree on the way that that
situation was dealt with
um
am I not allowed to have a say as as the
wife as the mother of that child yeah or
do I just listen to my husband no matter
what he says even though I feel that
what he's saying is wrong and the way
that he treated our son or the way that
he decided to deal with that situation
it feels like what you're doing is wrong
you both feel that way okay but then we
have to come to some kind of agreement
because that's but feelings are
temporary feelings aren't really I just
think women are emotionally with their
kids and I'm fine men very logical and
it's factual that a man would raise his
child better than a woman so I think you
have to have faith in your partner and
if he's a man you have to give him that
step above to say you know what you're
the man of the household if you don't
have that the whole structure of the
household doesn't have any foundations
really because a woman can't run it it's
impossible and it's a statistics say
that women at single parent households
and things like that are really awful
for children so I think you'd have to
give your man the upper hand at some
point there's no equality in the
household there's the man's role in a
woman's role that's what I believe
and the women and the women that
honestly do lead their households are
miserable yeah I mean you you guys see
the girls that wear the pants in the
relationship do they look happy
that's stressed yeah
but oh oh gosh I have a question all
right let's say we go back to the
beginning of feminism with the suffrage
movement if you had to fight if you're
options in order to vote was to fight in
the front line of combat would you give
it up
during war times no nope say the
question again please okay so if
in order to vote you had to be drafted
and in the front lines not just like
cooking in the Army go to wall basically
yeah go to war would you still want to
vote no yeah
no no no no no no
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible